You can even steer a non steerable square or round
parachute if there is wind by that goal.
Or pull in the B lines one side asymmetrical.
You can even influence the direction a little bit.
I mean that helps if you're drifting towards an obstacle in
the valley range for instance. And the behaviour for Beamer and
steerable, a reserve part of short is exactly the same like
for unsteerable. So you throw it, you wait to
opening. If it's not opening, you, you
need to do something that it opens.
And this is something that all the pilots don't know.
They throw the reserve and they're waiting and they're
waiting and nothing happens. So if nothing happens, you, you
have to get active. And there are ways to open the
reserve parachute, which has a, a problem of a malfunction.
There are chances. And then when the opening is is
in process, start working on your on your para glider.
Try to neutralize it as quick as possible.
And then until now we are at the same stage steerable and and
this is perfect because most of the time a lot of openings they
take and place pretty low. And if there is time, if you
have a steerable reserve, then you keep your paddle glider,
your neutralized paddle glider that is in AB4 or C4, you keep
both risers in one hand and you just grab with your opposite
hand. You just grab one brake line and
you pull it. And because we have on the beam
and we have pre brake opening set up, if you pull one line, 1
brake line with this one, you can turn to both sides because
the other side is still pre brake.
And this way makes sense makes. Sense.
And this way, if you're lucky, you can avoid an obstacle.
We're not talking about the sport landing.
It's not necessary. You just need to avoid flying
into a power line or into a house or, you know, into a
river. But that's what people should
learn. And you have to train this if if
it's the first time and you've never tried it before, it won't
work. And you know, I remember when I
did my first reserve opening above water, it was it really
saved my life. Later on, one year later when I
was above water, I was meters. We did some tests.
I was really young when I was above water and I saw these
little tiny boats underneath the lake.
I was so scared. And just imagine I was thinking
when I would be above the pumps in scroll Valley winds and you
know, beside of rocks, I would even be more scared.
But that's the point. If time has come, if the ship
hits the van, the decent decision must come like boom,
now it's time for the reserve. No matter where you are, it's
your last chance and you have to go for it.
So train this, train this even more than once.
It really it's a game changer. For me it was.
Quickly, why did you use the word?
If you're lucky you might skip the obstacle?
Like is there a sure short way ish to skip the obstacle with a
regalo? Because in that regalo what
regalo is supposed to be? Or are you talking about
blowbacks and those kind of scenarios?
Another thing is that, you know, when people decide for a
stealable reserve, they think they can steer like steering
like their paraglider. And that's not the case.
It is the case if you do hundreds of openings like
Addito, I, I do sport landing with my Robolo.
I can, but you, you have to, to train yourself.
But if the, if you never trained before, if it's the first time,
then you know, that's what I explained before, that's what we
train to our customers. You know, neutralize your padded
lighter, go for your brake line look, check the landscape, look
where you are drifting to. And if you have time, if you
have enough height, then just, you know, try to land somewhere
where there are no obstacles.